欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,第二节我们来继续讲关于如何去做市场分析
主要就是关于如何判断市场潜力和选对重量市场,选对行业
那么这一小节就是以行业作为维度去分析市场的大小和需求
选对行业下的二级类目和三级类目
这对于选品型的公司和选类目型的公司是非常重要的
首先我们先点击查行业,进入到这个板块,那么这个板块就会显示从上网下排序, 展示非常非常多的类目, 那么通过这些类目的买家规模指数, 买家数, 年同比, 供需比, 转化率, 等等, 这些维度来判断哪一个类目更加具有潜力, 哪一个类目它的一个市场量更大, 以及它的需求更大, 这些数据维度都能够
帮助我们去做决策, 比如说我们看到的这个南庄, 我们看到它的买家规模指数, 可以判断出整个行业的一个市场规模
第二个就是市场增速, 也就是判断市场它的增量, 它还在增长, 比去年还在增长
如果它是负数的话, 那么说明现在的这个市场在下跌, 这些流量在下跌
那么供需比, 我们可以判断出, 市场竞争度, 也就是供需比越大, 那么它的竞争, 就会越小, 转化率, 那么可以判断的出, 市场真实的需求度, 如果很多人来逛产品, 而没有发旋盘, 没有发贴幕, 没有成交订单, 那么都不代表着他们有真实的需求, 所以我们只需要通过这几个数据维度, 就能够非常清楚的判断的出,
我们这个店铺里面, 优先做哪个库幕
我这边已经把这些指标的一个整体的判断的一些维度给到大家了
那么大家如果对这些指标还不是很理解的话
再重新的看一遍
还有一个就是表格分析
我们将以上的数据复制出来统计
比如说买家规模指数,买家数年同比, 供需比, 转化率
这几个维度做成一个数据表格
前面加一个类目,比如男装, 然后的女装, 要到什么其他的品类, 那么统计在这个表格里面, 做个数据的排序, 那么是不是我们如果想要转化率高的, 那么我们降序, 是不是就知道, 我们整个行业里面哪些品类的转化率更高, 我们在推广, 以及我们在发产品的时候, 优先发哪种类型的产品, 那么这个也是一样的逻辑, 他这里面都有一些具体的数据,
还有排名,你看还有这些数据, 这些数据其实我们都可以把它采取出来, 放在表格里面去进行一个统计, 那么统计出来之后就有非常直观的到哪些数据, 排名怎么样, 哪些背幕, 它的一个转化怎么样, 都可以看得出, 那么接下来我们就到后台来看一下具体是怎么样操作的, 首先我们打开的是市场参谋, 市场参谋之后就来到这个板块有两个路径,
第一个路径是查行业, 第二个路径是查国家, 那么我们这一小节主要是讲通过查国家去分析的, 你看我查国家之后, 这里是不是一级类目, 服装, 集配式, 如果你的店铺跟我的不一样, 那么这个一级类目是不一样的, 下面它会有很多种二级类目, 你看男装, 女装, 休闲, 再往下的话, 你看还有很多很多, 这是二级类目, 通过这些二级类目, 我们来看一下,
这些数据, 买家规模, 这些供需比, 转化率, 等等这些, 你看, 规模不一样, 但是转化率也是不一样的, 有些转化率很高, 有些转化率很低, 那么供需比也是一样的, 如果你想要更清楚的去做一个对比, 你可以把他们这些数据复制出来, 放到你的表格, 做一个筛选, 那么你就知道, 我优先做哪个品类, 以及我要做哪些产品优先,
我们就能够从更加有效的方向进行切入去做店铺了
这个就是关于如何判断我们的一个市场潜力, 选对增量市场, 选对行业